- [Narrator] Between the
snow-covered mountains
deep in Gangwon Province in South Korea
sits one of the country's
hottest spa crazes,
and we mean literally hot.
(bouncy electronic music)
(bouncy piano music)
- [Narrator] Charcoal
played an important role
in Korean culture.
Its use dates back over 2,600 years
to heat homes, cook food,
and ward off bad energy.
Seo Jong-won and his father make charcoal
from oak wood that is
unique to this region.
It's an arduous process
that starts and ends
with kilns or giant ovens.
- [Narrator] The kilns
function as a traditional
Korean sauna, a treatment
that has been happening
for hundreds of years.
Customers pay a small fee to spend time
sweating out their
toxins in the hot rooms.
- [Narrator] And a national
attraction it will stay.
Seo Jong-won has no plans of slowing down
the family business.
(lively, bouncy music)
(bell ringing)